It’s 400 miles to Azna.
Long way to go for a party.
Face it David, we’re lost.
That’s the turn.
No it’s not.
This is the turn!
No, David.
Don’t be so bloody stupid.
It was an accident.
He stepped out in front of us.
We didn’t want the police showing up.
Poking their noses into everything.
You got into a car with a drunk,
which makes you an accessory.
Feel like I’ve been an accessory
for a long time now.
Now listen, are you
going to mope all weekend,
or are you going to enjoy yourself?
It’s not a crime to enjoy yourself,
you know.
I suppose I can make the effort.
Did he mention money?
No.
He wants you to return with them
to bury the boy.
It is customary in these parts.
People disappear here.
They just vanish.
What did you do with his ID?
Bury it.
They didn’t just hit him.
They ran over him.
Maybe more than once.
What do they call it in your country?
Roadkill.
There’s nowhere to run,
nowhere to hide.
Has it occurred to you
that he might actually be planning
something a lot nastier
than anything you can anticipate?
You’ve forgotten about my husband.
Yes I have.
And so have you.
Why did you come here?